hello when the common dos games come
2014 I'm Daniel Dwyer oh my god I'm
shaman Venus banana your German is
impeccable I'm impressed I also came
dressed for the occasion this wasn't
just stuff we found around this
apartment we're staying in I swear but
who cares about attire and in time like
this we're here to talk about video
games and only just a couple of hours
ago we went to the Microsoft yes yeah we
went to the microsoft conference here at
Gamescom and we got I invite dry talking
points to share with you folks first one
being exclusives they announced some
explosives revealed some gameplay for
previously announced stuff I guess the
big news is that rise of the Tomb Raider
rise of the planet of the to rise of the
planet of the tomb raider coming out
fall or a holiday 2015 yeah is going to
be quote an xbox exclusive this is kind
of crazy like it's a big title obviously
Crystal Dynamics the first game they
released this is a straight-up sequel to
the rebrand the tomb raider yeah very
popular right game that came out as well
but it seems it seemed kind of a given
is this ever gonna come in on something
else right I think I think the official
line is that it's going to be a
exclusive or holiday 2015 so I kind of
suggests that potentially there will be
a ps4 and PC version down the line so
here's the weird thing about this to me
is it's one thing to do a third-party
exclusive exclusive like scalebound the
game they announced with platinum at e3
which is a new IP it's a completely
different thing to take the sequel to a
multi-platform game and remove the other
platforms on the equation people who
play that game on like ps3 and pc are
naturally going to be pissed yeah they
won't be happy it's gonna be literate
they'll be shaking their heads in there
it's another game a new IP the first
game that week Oh Sam leg kick of course
came onto the stage to show us quantum
break quantum break all right what's
your takeaway because mine I feel like
this is a game of two halves there's the
third person shooter which looks fine
yeah and then like the time unit time
manipulation stuff which look cool they
know polish why's it looks incredible
but the problem is every time I see that
game the actual action seems to be like
not only just like cover shooting linear
like when you came up to that boss fight
in the demo they showed he literally
threw a cab and it closed off the area
you came in through like 1998 first
person shooter style right and so you
know it looked cool he was using those
two saying Harris all the time the one
that was kind of like zoom around and
you know Alton like the flash almost and
maybe kick them or attack them aside and
then that weird time manipulation thing
that's like put them in a bubble so you
could like load up like 12 yeah you
shoot all the bullets at the bubble and
then the bubble disappears and the
bullets go at the guy I'm horrible yeah
but all that stuff on the bridge was
cool all the licenses story beaten you
know yeah Alan Wake I think like some of
that stuff remedy are pretty good at
doing yeah absolutely i mean it's
definitely a narrative and story driven
studio and that's kind of why I'm most
interested in this game like the
shooting stuff you know I look good
enough but in I mean remedy they make
they make some cool story so I'm excited
to check out and it looks next-gen it
does current gen I believe the phrase
you're looking for is next gen ii
anyways on to the next section let's
talk about bundles cuz they announced i
bungled three different bundles probably
the most exciting one is the call of
duty advanced warfare bundle it looks
really good because a it's got the
limited edition kind of like
livery on it be it comes with a one
terabyte hard drive yes obviously twice
the capacity of the standard xbox one
but that does come at a price it is five
hundred dollars instead of get entered
four hundred dollars now that they've
removed connect from the packaging say
mini oreos as well yeah unfortunately
and but there are two other bundles that
are coming errors which r.i.p I guess
the standard price of four hundred
dollars turn to your right one of which
is basically sort of copy paste what did
it last year with be per SOP for 15 this
year and will be bundled in there
there's also some exclusive fifa
ultimate team and legends are going to
be thrown in there I got to meet one of
the legends one of those legends Peter
Schmeichel yep or as I like to call him
danish Gary Busey you have to see the
similarity it's there right well I
suppose you see the similarity I got to
I got to stick hammer right up in his
face I'm even a wide the done you
introduced him to the concept of the
video selfie which I very much
appreciate he shook my hand even though
I said I was an absolute so I appreciate
that right cuz he played for United
right exactly now there was a third
bundle which is the white sunset
overdrive bundle yes which that thing
would look so nice next to that white
destiny of like saving for wouldn't it
it was if that was the one that when it
popped up on the screen everyone went
hmm yeah except for that one guy hahaha
I was sitting behind us in the
conference who and one stays I got he
was just had his face buried in his
hands like I'm gonna be there at his
phone went off probably at least four
times during that conference and it
wasn't like kind of like a subdued
ringtone it was like loud German rock
yeah it was like some weird metal in the
end he answered and the answer is at one
point which was amazing that's a bold
move but kudos to him he didn't want the
sunset overdrive bundle for me you do
anyways on to the third yes and final
takeaway of that press conference idea
tech ID and Xbox you know Microsoft from
since e3 they've been kind of like
focusing their efforts on games at their
press conferences they
kind of screwed the pooch the past
couple years on focusing on a lot of
like TV entertainment stuff but it's
back to games an ID at Xbox is kind of
an example yeah unless is obviously what
they they sort of revealed at last year
and I guess this year we're finally
seeing the fruits of that labor a bunch
of cool games on there a goat simulator
from one and perhaps it's a console
exclusive or timed all this stuff was
like very timed exclusivity they said
like these were these games would all
make their console they'd be on it
that's one as superhot was in there as
well yes I game this office have really
successful Kickstarter to do this year
and what's the bunch of other stuff oh
and space engineers space engineers a
game that's been out on Steam early
access for a little while but it's
coming to Xbox one and that game's been
pretty popular on steamer thing alright
so overall Xbox press conference at
Gamescom 2014 thumbs up thumbs down
thumbs up only because a games thumbs it
to hear ya maybe like sixty percent
based entirely on the factors usually
they don't do much at Gamescom anyway
yeah they're last year's conference was
kind of a wet fart yeah this one was
much better not too bad we have a
continuing coverage of gamescom 2014 all
over the site in fact the Sony
conference is on right now so by the
time this has gone up on the Internet
should be a breakdown of that as well so
thank you very much for myself from
Klaus and from Sean our vetoes end
goodbye
you